[Applause]
hey guys 2014 is finally here but that
doesn't mean that I've forgotten about
2013 last year was probably one of the
best years of my life and it's all
thanks to you guys and what you guys
have done to support me in the channel
we've come so far and we've done so many
things and I wouldn't be able to do it
without you so let's take a look back at
some of my favorite videos from last
year enjoy oh okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
ah I must steal this num gonna go away I
was born and I was born awesome there's
something here
there's something here oh I'm so excited
[Laughter]
it's like backwards and upside down and
like the worst version is Hitler I don't
quite feel like myself when I crush your
balls like little walnuts
what the hell the balls have gone out of
control in the sands you play as one of
four elements how do I aim how am i
jumping and walking if I lost both my
legs and an arm and my boy the crazed
but scabbard which dudes be fine with me
because every time like it's right there
oh my god yes that's it oh let it claw
it off my face
[Music]
a sad penis is a small died and what to
hell or if this is just what life is now
what's this you want to eat me leave
your door Koosh brother alone everyone
knows that kids who wear glasses are
stupid idiots
[Music]
[Laughter]
I got four raw chicken breast and some
an old fat and apparently this waffle
it's wearing some clothes because I'm
getting a bunch of cloth and I don't
think these developers are clear on what
animals are made of
[Music]
there you go that wasn't all the videos
but if I included all the videos doing
two videos a day it would have been way
way too long and I just want you guys to
know that we've come so far last year we
had under a hundred thousand subscribers
now we have well over a million and that
number is not lost on me it's still
incredible it still like makes me feel
great I still follow every single sub we
get all my friends can tell you I obsess
over the channel every day and I love
doing it I love getting out of bed I
love working on the channel and I love
it because it is just so much fun to be
able to entertain you guys so thank you
guys so much for everything and as you
know last year I had a New Year's
resolution it was to get fifty thousand
dollars raised over the entire year for
charity and we have done much more than
that we've done more than that in just
the last charity we did for extra life
and that was in like one month we beat
the entire year's goal so thank you guys
so much for believing in these causes
and for the new New Year's resolution
for 2014 and I know we're gonna blow
this goal out of the wallet and I know
we're gonna blow this goal out of the
water I want to raise three hundred
thousand dollars for charity and that
may seem like a lot but that's just one
and a half times what we've already
raised for charity and the difference
between going from last January raising
$6,000 for kunos to nearly seventy four
thousand dollars for extra life this
past month
it's just it's astronomical with the
more number of people that we have the
more good we're able to do so thank you
guys so much
oh and $74,000 because we raised fifty
four thousand dollars ourselves but
there was an added bonus towards
Cincinnati Children's Hospital for
making them the most improved Hospital
in the entire country that's something
that you guys did and thank you guys so
much for that it is absolutely
incredible so just from the bottom of my
heart thank you for that person
but next year we're gonna do so much
more and I have so many things planned
for you guys in terms of great videos
that I want to do fun stuff that I'm
gonna do an amazing new projects that
are just gonna blow your mind so thank
you guys again this year was great and
2014 is gonna be even better so thank
you all so much for watching click the
there's nothing there don't click
anything just thank you guys for
everything thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I will see you
[Music]